as doctors as friends as human beings we
all try to do the best we can
after 19 seasons in over 400 episodes
Ellen Pompeo is saying goodbye to Grace
Sloan God says greatly you just let us
toast you it's still Grace she's still
there in spirit and that's the house
that gray built so she's always there
lumen
just has to step away for a little bit
while we mourn the exit of Dr Meredith
gray one of TV's most iconic characters
ETS taking a look back at Ellen's
greatest Gray's Anatomy moments of all
time flashing Back to Where it All Began
we don't have to do that thing where you
know I say something and then you say
something and then somebody cries and
there's like a moment yeah
she gets some sleep you look like crap
I look better than you
it's not possible
it was also the moment that introduced
fans to her first love story of the
series Pam
[Music]
worth it
you're my person mayor why do you care
what I think
because you're my person you are my
person you will always be my person I'm
your person
while Ellen revealed to ET that the
iconic line with Christina Yang is one
of her favorite quotes from the show she
also admitted this one Takes the Cake
Christina
make it stop making stuff
I can remember that scene where she was
hysterical in the scene that's probably
the best Gray's Anatomy moment of all
time the pilot episode also marked the
start of Meredith's romance with
McDreamy which led to this very raw and
pivotal scene in season two so pick me
choose me
love me
another huge season two moment when
Meredith bravely steps in to hold her
hand on a bomb lodged inside an injured
patient
[Music]
[Music]
how much
Hey listen it's drama yeah we need drama
fast forward to season four one of the
biggest romantic gestures played out on
the show and I did this stupid
embarrassing humiliating corny thing and
I was just gonna tell you that this over
here
is our kitchen and this is our living
room
and over there that's the room where our
kids could play I'm still mad at you and
I don't know if I trust you I want to
trust you but I don't know if I do so
I'm just gonna try I'm gonna try and
trust you because I believe that we can
be extraordinary together rather than
ordinary apart and I want to be
from a house of candles to a single
Post-It note these two had fans
emotional over their intimate and
improvised exchange of vows
this is our wedding I post it
um
if you sign it
[Music]
now
I kissed the bride
that was a very special bond that it was
just there was a magic to our connection
three seasons later the couple welcomed
a new member to the family baby Zola
[Music]
is that our baby
[Music]
[Music]
but with a beautiful moment comes a
tragic one season 11 brought a
heartbreaking goodbye
[Music]
hearts
it's okay
you go and if I lay here after getting
struck by a car Derek was pronounced
brain dead leaving Meredith in tears but
showing she's the embodiment of strength
as she made the decision to let him go
three years later the world of Gray's
Anatomy celebrated Meredith's
professional Journey when she won the
prestigious Harper Avery award the
Harper Avery for surgical Innovation
goes to
Dr Meredith Gray
thank you
I think I'm exactly like Meredith gray
I'm incredibly flawed and I say what's
on my mind I think we're probably pretty
similar but I could not perform
surgeries that's for sure rounding out
Meredith's biggest moments in Gray's
history when season 17 had viewers
thinking they were mcdreaming at the
site of this reunion
[Music]
you love me God knows I love you
I'll be right here when you're ready
yeah fans had to do a double take when
Derek appeared once again in Meredith's
dream after catching covet trying to
reinvent the show and continually trying
to reinvent the show is the challenge at
this point and after numerous iconic
moments Meredith is scrubbing out of the
or but she'll make her final return for
season 19 in February
[Music]
this is very thoughtful and ridiculous
God Saves gray will you just let us
toast you
[Music]
foreign